[Music]
hallelujah
praise the lord today is june 15
2021 and california
by order of lord newsom
is officially open i'm actually not even
sure what that means and half the people
are going to keep wearing masks and
hiding in their bunkers
but apparently california is open
it's very exciting june 15 2021 i'm dave
rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
as always tap the
subscribe button the notification bell
share the videos blah blah blah
we're going to be talking about newsome
and
reopening california and that he gave
himself powers to close down
at any time we're going to get to that
that's the
little asterisk in there you know don't
read the fine print but yeah that's
happening
and then we've got uh 30 minutes of q a
from our friends
over at reubenreport.locals.com for you
today before i get to any of that
guys i'm drinking black rifle coffee
right now watch this
delicious black rifle coffee company is
a veteran-owned coffee company serving
premium coffee to people who love
america
veteran ceo and founder evan hafer spent
over seven years
on the ground overseas with u.s special
forces and as a cia contractor black
rifle coffee company is continually
committed to supporting veteran
law enforcement and first responder
causes this summer they invite you to
enjoy your coffee
by that they don't just mean the great
taste of america's coffee
but the more places you drink it the
passion and adventure it fuels and
inspires and the entertainment they
serve along the way
whether you're brewing the perfect cup
of coffee before kicking ass at work or
cracking a can of 300 on your next
backcountry mission
black rifle coffee company is here to
fuel your way
wherever the summer takes you they
import their high quality coffee beans
from all over the world and roast
five days a week at their facilities in
manchester tennessee
and salt lake city utah the team at
black rifle
is continually researching experimenting
with new roasting methods
and coffee origins and i kid you not i
drink black coffee
black rifle coffee every single morning
purchase
black rifle coffee at
blackriflecoffee.comruben
and use code ruben at checkout for 20
off your purchase
and your first coffee club order fuel
your summer with america's coffee
black rifle coffee and now back to me
all right guys so as i said today
is june 15th this is the completely
arbitrary day that lord newsom the evil
disney cartoon character villain
has decided california can open it's a
little unclear to me what that means
because over the last couple weeks even
here in crazy cali the traffic's been
nuts
things have been opening up i've been to
a couple restaurants
some people are not wearing masks social
distancing seems like it's completely
gone
even the the rioters and the people
burning down buildings
uh seem to be getting back to their
normal activities
so it's an interesting thing but in any
event june 15th is here today is the day
that the whole thing's open but as i
mentioned before there's a little
asterisk
next to open because gavin newsom if you
don't think he
in the last year and a half usurped
enough power from the people and did
a whole bunch of stuff that he didn't
have any right to do well now he's
ensuring that he can kind of do it at
any
time he wants to going forward we've got
some quotes here from
fee.org with one of the lowest covet 19
case rates in the country a 70 plus
percent adult vaccination rate and
widespread reopening set for june 15th
the pandemic is finally on the lane in
california
but governor gavin newsom is still
refusing to give up
his emergency powers california is set
to end
most coronavirus restrictions on june
15th but governor
newsom is not lifting the state of
emergency
local media outlet kcra 3 reports
newsom is keeping emergency powers given
to him by a court in his back pocket
in case things go south but newsom is
setting a timeline on his emergency
powers
that could let him hold on to them for
years or even the rest of his time in
office
insisting that the state of emergency
can only lapse when the coronavirus is
extinguished
or vanished gives the governor license
to cling onto his expanded powers
essentially
forever so newsom is setting standards
that could allow him to
never hang up his crown this is an
unacceptable act of authoritarianism
that has
no place in a free society the
people at fee.org know a little
something about freedom
of course when newsome says i'll put
down my emergency powers you know when
the emergency is over
very palpatine right wasn't that what
palpatine was gonna do i'll set these
emergency powers down i
i love democracy right like that's what
this guy's doing
the idea that we're opening up now and
that he can just
we're closing down kovid six the south
indian variant whatever he might come up
with
is deeply dangerous and all this guy
wants his power
and i hope he loses the recall and it
would be nice if you ended up in jail
i'm sure there's a reason for it this is
not a good man all right before we get
to the q a i'm very excited to be
welcoming raise american as a new
sponsor to the reuben report
a company who raises the bar for premier
organic grass-fed beef all
over the country for more than 15 years
raise american has been honing
its processes to provide lovers of beef
the ultimate eating experience from the
feed to the cattle to the steak
raise american raises the standard of
what american organic beef ought to be
raise american cattle come from humanely
treated animals reared
on small independent american farms
farms run by family farmers and ranchers
adhering to some of the strictest
animal welfare and sustainable farming
protocols
healthy cattle make healthy beef and no
one knows that better than the team at
raise american
raise american focuses on sustainability
which is why they work closely with
these family farms
to raise grass-fed organic cattle which
spend most of their lives grazing
pastures
in the fresh open air grazing in a way
that will regenerate the soil
instead of depleting it raise american
is 100 organic 100 grass-fed
100 percent american go to
raiseamerican.com right now to order and
learn more good for you good for our
planet and good for america
and now back to me and let me just tell
you they sent us a ton of meat you guys
know i'm grilling all the time like
seriously delicious
juicy good stuff all right
let's do a little q a guys craig says
what do the conservatives need to focus
on to win congress in the 2022 election
thanks for all the support you are doing
and on a personal note your husband's
website looks amazing and definitely
provides
some inspiration for new recipes to try
if you want to find out more about that
and watch
and see some of the meat that i'm
grilling go to davidscookbook.com as for
what the republicans need to do
in 2022 i mean i think it's sort of
happening already which is kind of just
be sane right like that really is it
you know it's funny because you guys
obviously know my feelings about the
democrats they've all lost their mind i
don't know where any of the decent
liberals are like show me anyone that
will stand up to the radicals
they want to put racism into everything
they want the government to do
everything they want to tax the hell out
of everybody
they want to get rid of police
departments and the litany of like crazy
things they want to do
so pretty much the republicans just have
to be like hey
hello we don't don't want to do that
we're we're not that those guys i don't
think the republicans actually have to
do much i think the messaging has to be
hey
we love america these guys don't we're
proud of this country these guys aren't
we don't want all your money these guys
do we hopefully will cut some spending
and regulations
that stuff often the republicans don't
do when they're in power but we want you
to keep more of your tax dollars
we don't want to go to the crazy wars
like it's all all of the sensible stuff
is on the conservative side right now so
just be
somewhat of a decent communicator in
those ideas and i guess part of the
problem is that there aren't a lot of
republicans that that do that very
effectively there are some guys that do
it i think rand paul does it well
obviously ted
cruz does it well there are a couple
that do well obviously
you know my feelings about ron desantis
doing it incredibly well
but that really is the key just being
like hey you see the stuff that these
guys want to do they want eight-month
abortions
they want 15 minimum wage in a time when
the economy is depressed and the middle
class is disappearing
like they're gonna basically raise a
group of racists and they want
reparations like
all of the banana stuff is over here so
hey maybe we don't have the answers for
everything but we're kind of decent over
here and i know they call us racists and
bigots and nobody wants to be called
that but you know if you hang out with
us for a little bit you'll find out
we're not that way
i think like some messaging around that
like we can't solve all your problems we
like america
we're decent we're happy um you know
like we're trying but like we're not
trying to control you
that's pretty good storm says before
this what was your favorite job and why
i mean man i had
a lot of odd jobs over the years when i
was doing stand-up at night i would do
all sorts of crazy stuff during the day
you know i did like bartending and
catering for a bunch of
uh catering companies like in new york
city and in the suburb areas
and i really enjoyed that like i enjoy
well first off when you're doing it like
at a catering company you're usually
working with other actors and comedians
so a lot of like cool people i never
really like the actors actually but like
the comedians
like there's a lot of laughing
throughout the day and just like fun
stuff but i liked bartending a lot of
the
catering gigs because we'd be in long
island or we'd be in westchester you
know
new york suburb areas and i liked going
to like private parties and bartending
because you can really figure out like
who's wasted and you can see like the
family dynamics
and like when grandma comes up for like
her fourth white wine spritzer
in an hour in westchester you can find
out a lot
about that family so i always thought
like little catering gigs
were actually kind of fun and you know
at the end they let you eat a little bit
of the filet mignon if it hasn't been
eaten and
that kind of stuff was fun and then of
course you guys know i was assistant
manager of electronics boutique now
known as gamestop
in broadway mall in hicksville long
island that was my first job
at a college so i moved video games
nobody moved more pokemon red in 99 than
me
okay sally says i'm starting to see
pushback against the craziness
do you see it too or is it wishful
thinking on my part no there absolutely
is pushback i think
i think maybe the silver lining of biden
winning
and us being where we're at at the
moment is that if
trump had won they would be so crazy
trying to destroy trump that it wouldn't
allow a certain amount of people to wake
up
this is the best way i can give you the
silver lining on this thing that because
of the
the polarity related to trump and that
trump was sort of the center of the
universe for so many people
and whatever they believed sort of
orbited around trump
with trump slightly out of the equation
right now i think
the left has just made it very clear
that they were bananas whether
trump was around or not for all the
reasons that i explained in that first
question there
like they're going for everything
california is trying to pass a
reparations bill right now
nobody in my family owned slaves i
certainly never owned slaves and even if
someone in my family did own slaves
generations back i wouldn't be guilty
for their sins so like they're going
crazy on all of these different things
all and and of course the crt stuff is
the most dangerous
which and then you they trot out obama
there to like mock the country
because people are basically pushing
back against teaching racism
and obama's like oh but they should you
know the republicans should really be
worried about the things that matter
like climate change it's like give me a
break dude like come on man
to quote joe biden come on man um so i
don't think it's wishful thinking i
think that because
biden is in charge and trump is largely
out of the equation although he's
starting this touring gig with
bill o'reilly and as i've said before
you know i think he's going to act as
sort of the
the bodyguard if desantis does decide to
run in 2024
but with him sort of sidelined a little
bit at least i think this idea
that the the democrats are just becoming
what they are and and that's good for
people to see and and it's up free
it's up for you to choose like do you
want your children to
you know grow up in like a completely
racist
backward self-hating world or do you
want them to grow up in the america that
most of us have come
to love and i think i'm going to choose
the latter
mia says did you always want kids or has
it just become more important to you as
you got older
you know i talked a little bit about
this in don't burn this book
i never really wanted kids and i never
well i never really thought about it
because also like
when i was sort of coming of age and in
my early 20s and everything else i was
actually still really struggling
with my sexuality and and so i never i
sort of just lived day-to-day
and it was sort of like it was way
before gay marriage where i could never
even see a horizon where i could live
in a normal relationship or have like a
a normal
family situation or be a father or any
of that like it was so crazy and i
that makes i guess that makes it sound
like i'm like from the 20s like in my
day we couldn't do all those things
but like that's how quickly things
change and by the way that's the best
argument for equality not equity
the best argument for equality of course
is that two adults should be able to
make whatever decisions they want just
like any two other adults
should be allowed to make but i never
thought about it that way and as i
mentioned before david's a little
younger than me we've been together
about 10 years now
he grew up in a time where he was like
oh i'm gay nobody really cared
it was okay he knew he was going to be
married he knew he was going to have
kids and then i was on tour with jordan
peterson and jordan
would often talk about how for most
people
you would always say there are some
exceptions but for most people
the process of becoming a
parent and then becoming a grandparent
is just such a unique
piece of the human experience that to
live a fully actualized life you have to
do that
and i would hear him say this overnight
or you know every night over the course
of basically a year and a half you know
hundreds of times
some version of that and i'd see people
in the audience
talking about it i talked to people
after the show and there were young
parents there and i'd meet grandparents
and it was like well am i somehow the
exception to the rule
like am i and i started thinking that i
wasn't and then i knew that i was with
someone who wants kids and
uh and now i'm looking forward to being
a father and as i mentioned on the show
last week our surrogate did
actually just have um a second
miscarriage which
obviously sucks and we're going to keep
going and it's going to take some time
and
i'll be 45 in about two weeks so i'm not
going to be the youngest dad at the
soccer field but
uh hopefully the the old bones will hold
up so i can still play catch with this
kid
um these kids if it all turns out well
kevin says with the upcoming book and
the virus on the wane
will there finally be a tour yes
hallelujah so i just had my book editor
here as i mentioned on the show
yesterday
we're putting the final touches on the
second book and we'll
have an announcement uh in july for the
pre-sale and we're going to do all sorts
of giveaways for the locals community
and signings and all sorts of cool stuff
and i'm really psyched about the book
because it really is the next version of
that was my defense of liberalism
the liberals have failed liberalism what
do we do now
i think there's some new ideas in there
i'm really i'm really proud of it i
limited the star wars references
i think it's the right blend of like
info and humor and all that good stuff
one of the things i really missed about
don't burn this book
was that i was supposed to be on a tour
i had like a 50 city tour
that was going to be you know basically
all of may into june
and then we were working on a european
tour and we were working on an
australian tour and i was gonna
just go to wherever i was literally
gonna go wherever that's what i said to
the guys if someone wants me somewhere i
will show up
and talk about this book that's what i
want to do and that year and a half
with jordan was just just so freaking
spectacular
so i cannot wait to get back out there
and tour the book and and
you know do q and a's and fiddle around
with you guys and have fun and get
people out there together so yes there
absolutely will be
though i will say this because the book
isn't coming out until april of 2022
i'm definitely going to start doing some
road stuff starting in the fall again
i miss it we're also looking into maybe
doing a monthly thing here in los
angeles we found a venue that we kind of
like like a dinner and show
kind of thing so stay tuned on all that
elijah says what's your favorite
biden gaffe well you know i'll go
i'll go early biden like before biden
was president you may remember
first term obama presidency joe biden as
the vp
was on meet the press and he basically
just blurted out
that barack obama was for gay marriage
even though at the time
barack obama was not for gay marriage at
least that uh
via a political calculation was not for
gay marriage and then what happened was
over the next like two three weeks obama
basically had to admit
or or finally the pressure became too
great to bear but obama came out for gay
marriage
so a biden gaffe because he clearly was
not supposed to say that i remember the
press around it the next couple days in
the white house press secretary and
everything else
he was not supposed to say that obama
had a private feeling that was against
his public willing
and that also shows you that these
people are all sort of panderers
and as i always say the progressives of
2040 they're going to burn down the
obama library because he wasn't for
gay marriage and if we're to believe
that gay rights are as important as
civil rights and minority rights and all
of those things well then
the way we would look back and think
that thomas jefferson must be a racist
barack obama must be a homophobe so
congrats joe on that one
tom says what's your guess on the month
and year that biden leaves office oh
really getting me on this one you know i
predicted at the beginning of this thing
that he would not
make it to the end that they will put
him out to pasture before
i i still stand by that but i think
they're going to push it as
far as they can because think about it
the mainstream corporate press
is not showing any of the gaffes so the
gaffes that we show here
the puttering around and the mumbling
and the confusion and i don't know where
i am and what country is this and all
these things
you don't see that on cnn right you
don't see it on msnbc so they feel
that they can hide reality from a
certain set of people
and i think what they're going to really
try to do is you want to get bite into
as
close as to the end of the term as
possible because if i'm not mistaken
if then kamala harris took over you
could get eight years out of her so she
could finish the term and then you max
her out
at eight years so you want biden to go
as far as he can you keep this thing
going
we pretend that biden's in charge
basically for four years then she jumps
in in the last couple of months and then
they would want her
for eight years who they are i'm not
sure the
the the obama machine i don't know i
don't know exactly what it is but
they're gonna try
the real question i guess is does he
just break down before then like does it
just become
so obvious that even the propagandists
that cnn and msnbc like actually have to
cover that something ain't right with
this guy but you know again if you're
the
prime minister of or president of china
or your putin
or anyone that is you know considered a
rival of america
right now you're just licking your chops
because you're like that guy that guy
just ain't in charge and this is not a
serious
or strong country to lead the world brad
says
recently congresswoman laura bobert
brought a cardboard cutout of kamala
harris to the u.s mexico border
why do you think the real life not the
cardboard cutout
harris is avoiding going there it's
really interesting because it's like
every interview she goes into now which
she doesn't do that many interviews but
she did do some while she was
on this south american trip and she was
down there in guatemala which we talked
about
in all these media appearances they are
asking her why aren't you going to the
border why
i have been to the border no you haven't
oh i haven't but i haven't been to
europe like
she's just an extraordinary
artist why is she not going there it's a
good question like why wouldn't they
just send her there to shut everybody up
why wouldn't they just send her there to
be like well she did go there
that would that would shut half of you
people up just it wouldn't matter if she
did anything there or saw anybody
but that would seemingly quiet a whole
bunch of you guys you crazy right
wingers
so i don't know are they trying to like
just throw it in our faces
i think it's partly that but it's partly
that our our media here doesn't hold
them to account
so whatever is going on at the border
right now which does
seem from everything i can see to be far
worse of a disaster than anything under
trump because even
there's videos i mean you could see
these videos i'm not making it up guys
of of immigrants coming across not
immigrants you can see these videos of
of in effect mass groups of people that
we don't know where they're from
or what they're doing you can see them
coming across the border and then when
they get on video some of them are like
well biden's welcoming us trump was me
and biden's welcoming us
so do they want the border crisis like
do i want to go through that
if you take this thing to the end do the
democrats want it so that they can just
open up the borders and just assume that
all of these people are going to vote
for them because they're going to give
ubi to everybody and voting rights to
everybody and then they just have this
like permanent class
of voters you know you just give them
next to nothing and they think it's
something so they vote for you forever
sort of like
what the democrats have done with black
people for a long time and is that a
conspiracy theory i don't know
rose says is it a waste of time to
respond back to
the libs and progressives who think
newsom did a wonderful job
i want to find some way to reach them
why won't they wake up
i mean this is the age-old question with
these people it's like have you not
woken up at this time if your city is
burning down if your governor
and your mayor kept you in lockdown
while they ate at french laundry and
went to visit family members or flew to
mexico for vacation
and the all of the things that we now
know are happening in blue cities that
are not happening in red cities
i mean i was just in austin texas a
couple weeks ago for a speaking gig with
heritage
but the event was fantastic actually but
austin
which is like the blue blue blue center
of
texas there's homelessness everywhere
now there's just like sort of crazy
people wandering the streets there's
homeless tents it sort of reminded me of
home
up here in los angeles actually it was
quite nice uh that's exactly what my
friend said to me we were driving and i
was like
uh look at all this homelessness i can't
believe it's all oh doesn't it remind
you of home yeah
there you go that that's a problem and
it's not happening like why isn't that
happening in dallas why isn't that
happening in salt lake city
why isn't that happening in carmel by
the sea you know republican-run places
um so why won't they wake up you know
this is partly a branding thing i think
these people
are so they they fear the the bad
policies they fear the violence
they fear all that stuff but what they
really fear what my liberal friends
really fear more than anything else is
being called a conservative
clyde was really into that did you hear
the rattling there you like that one
claude
um what they really fear is being called
a conservative they fear that they will
be thought of as the evil people they
have said these people are
such evil for so long that they know if
they start coming i'm against gavin
newsom he caused lockdowns destroyed the
economy
you know did it all for no scientific
reason right there's
no evidence please somebody prove me
wrong
show me the side-by-side evidence that
lockdowns worked
and keeping things open didn't work
there's no evidence of it we don't even
have evidence at this point that masks
work again if you want to wear a mask
wear a mask
you want to get vaccinated get
vaccinated these people are just
you know it's like if you go so in on a
lie at some point
the lie almost overtakes you because you
can't get out you can't get out like
you've gone in so deep you've done
things
to get there that it's uh it would make
you look in the mirror and a lot of
people don't want to do that but
that doesn't mean it ain't worth the
effort amy says should we begin to
consider homeschooling children as a
more mainstream approach to educating
them yes
absolutely for sure you sort of must
i promise you i will not be sending my
children to
public schools that is a damn shame i
went to public schools david went to
public schools
i think that most of the people that go
into teaching go into it for a good
reason and then unfortunately they get
they get sort of mugged by progressive
orthodoxy they get mugged by the
teachers unions
um they get mugged by the fact that
unfortunately a lot of liberals don't
know what they believe
you know it's a whole bunch of stuff but
i can't see sending children to public
school
and that's a sucky situation because not
everyone has the time or the ability to
homeschool
i think you know one of the cool things
that's happening right now there's this
big push to fund students
not schools so this in essence the
government would give you x amount of
dollars you could send your children to
a public school or you could homeschool
them
but i think there's so many things on
the horizon that are going to come
related to schooling like i think
there's just going to be local pods
where you'll get 10 or
15 kids or maybe 40 kids together every
day and they'll maybe do it in different
people's houses or whatever
and yes it will change the way we all
socialized as young people like all of
those things will change but
i just think if you think outside of the
box there's so many options there
and always remember who doesn't want
school choice
who is a hundred percent against school
choice well it's gavin newsom
it's elizabeth warren who sent her own
children you know she's worth millions
of millions of dollars send her own
children
to private schools but she doesn't want
your children going to private school
she doesn't want your it was her
stepchildren is that right she sent her
stepchildren thank you for that
to private schools but she doesn't want
your children going to
charter schools and the reason that they
want all of your children
in their crappy public schools is
because that is the best
place to brainwash them it is simple as
that
bernie is not saying i want free college
for everybody so everybody can learn
libertarian economics no he's sending
them there because if you ever wanted to
brainwash a generation into believing
that the state is god
then do it at one of bernie's free
universities
uh sirona says what are some of your
favorite outdoor
activities to do well i love playing
basketball more than anything
probably like that's number one
absolutely just love i just love
shooting oops playing horse
uh you know i've got this torn acl on my
knee so i can't really play in in full
games anymore i'm thinking about getting
the surgery but it's it's a pretty
brutal surgery
a couple weeks just like laid up in bed
and then months of recovery but i'm
trying to decide what to do on that
um i really love gardening you know i
picked up gardening during the
the lockdowns and we have a pretty cool
rooftop garden it's just a bunch of
planters that we built ourselves
and we got peppers and we got tomatoes
and we got squash up there now and we
got
uh we got tons of strawberries we got a
couple
orange trees like we're just doing stuff
and i just love it and i love eating the
food and
i love you know pruning the plants and
all of that
good stuff so i would say basketball um
you know the gardening and i actually
just like taking walks like i really
clyde's right here today
i really like uh maybe we'll get caught
you want to get up on the table today
see you
he's not doing anything right now um
i like i like just walking the dog i
really do like just walking the dog
marilyn says what are your thoughts on
caitlyn jenner for governor you know
look we tried to reach out they haven't
got back to us
someone from the campaign did privately
reach out to me saying that maybe we
would
get together at some point and see
what's what she's welcome to do the show
i suppose
i i'm just not honestly i'm just not
sure if this thing is real or not again
everybody in california all however how
many people we got in cali
this must be like is it like 70 million
people how many people we got in cali
let's get let's get a number on that
however many there are i'll have a
number in one second however many there
are every single one of them would be
better than gavin newsom i would vote
for the crazy
lunatic meth addicted whack job
wandering around venice beach right now
uh before i would vote for gavin newsom
39.5 million people in 2019
in california uh we did lose some people
in california for the first time ever
in 2020 california had a net population
loss because
of gavin newsom rhiannon says what's
your favorite
city or national park in america well as
for city i mean
well i would say dc at the
at the in its best sense not in the dc
of the last two years
but dc with the history of america and
the monuments like i
love that stuff i've talked about it
before i love going to the washington
monument i love walking the mall
one of the highlights of my career i
guess in my life was
was speaking at the reason rally in like
2014 or so i spoke at the
at the at the mall like in front of the
giant reflecting pool like
forrest gump style it was it was pretty
incredible i love the jefferson memorial
which is a little off the beaten path
over there in the jfk memorial and just
all
uh i'm sorry not the jfk memorial the
mlk memorial like there's just so much
stuff there in the vietnam veterans
memorial like there's just so much
history and and you just feel this
incredible thing and that's why it's so
disappointing now
what's happening in dc and to that end
you know i'd say new york i
i lived in new york most of my formative
years you know sinatra
like if you can make it there you can
make it anywhere and i lived in those
years when i had
nothing and when i was a struggling
comic and i literally it was like
taking change out of my roommates you
know cup of
chock full of nuts coffee to uh to buy a
cup of coffee
and you know sleeping on cots and all
those struggle years which i now
sort of look back on as the good old
days like they were the good old days
wandering in new york city and
and and just growing up in new york city
that place with that incredible energy
and it was like everyone was there to do
something and build something and make
something of of themselves and like that
spirit has just been
extinguished that that's just very
disappointing which is a perfect segue
to margot if you're ever in new york
city area can you arrange a meet up this
site has kept me sane
the past year and i would love to meet
you and thank you in person
now that we can uh well thank you for
that um as for a new york city meetup
honestly the truth is i don't know that
i would do a new york city meetup like
i don't think it's that safe like when
when i do meetups you know we do them
for subscribers only at locals
that's not a perfect system because
obviously people could pay i suppose to
figure out where i am or
or any of that kind of i don't even like
thinking about it but new york city it
just doesn't seem like that safe to do
that sort of thing so i like
doing them more so in in red cities
however
if i say i like meeting people i really
do i actually love meeting you guys
so maybe we can figure out a little
something anyway
uh i am off well truth be told
i'm taping this the day before it's
airing right now you guys are watching
this thinking it's live
i'm actually taping this on monday
because i'm on a plane right now
going to florida so i'm in miami the
next couple days we're moving locals
down there
meeting investors it's just blowing up
as a city i'm going to be talking to the
mayor and a whole bunch of other stuff
so we may do a meet up either wednesday
night tomorrow night
or on friday we're trying to figure that
out and for more info you can
uh join us at reubenreport.locals.com
part one
of my interview with james lindsey so
when they tell you
this is the new meme out there from the
left
conservatives don't know what critical
race theory is they talk about it all
the time but they don't know what it is
i tell you what it is all the time
plenty of other people do as well james
lindsay has been one of the guys
talking about this for years distilling
it
to its disturbing racist roots and
and what it is and why it has become so
sort of ubiquitous and leaked into
everything in society
i've had james on the show over the
years on panels but this is the first
one on one we've ever done
part one is up on the youtube and the
full episode is up early and ad-free at
reubenreport.locals.com
and i hope to see some of you guys in
the miami area
and that's it see you later
you